[Applause]
[Music]
time now for another pft on yahoo sports
peter king mike floria all the big
stories in the national football league
one of big questions right now peter in
the aftermath of week 11 the monday
night game the buccaneers losing at home
to the rams are the tampa bay buccaneers
overrated
i mean
i they're the most mysterious team in
football how do you beat green bay by a
thousand and carolina by a thousand and
ten
and uh
and then play the way they have played
at times this year now i will say this
the
the the kryptonite for the tampa bay
buccaneers is a strong defensive front
they have proven weak this year
when they play a front
that gets in brady's face
and stops them from being able to run
very well i mean in this game monday
night it would seem like it was second
and eight at best almost all the time
and you know i'm sure that's not
absolutely true but
they could not get ronald jones or
leonard fournette going for the most
part that hurt him and every time brady
had to make a throw particularly in the
second half you know he didn't have as
much time as tom brady needs
and so to me i i just think that when
they face
a really good front seven
you know like god forbid they play the
steelers in the super bowl
you know if they ever reach there
because i think brady could get sacked
nine times and it could be ugly but i
think
what tampa bay needs to do
is they need to develop
more of a two tight end offense
to try to give
that front a little bit a chance to
block
a great front seven
you're absolutely right about that peter
and they have gotten away from it
because now they have antonio brown and
they need to have antonio brown on the
field with mike evans and chris godwin
so they go to three receiver sets and
they don't use two tight ends and it
doesn't give tom brady enough time and
we know
from the losses to the giants in the
super bowl and other periodic occasions
when brady would have a horrible game
when it's pressure up the middle that's
when he has a hard time in this offense
in tampa trying to get him to throw the
ball down the field i think he wants to
show that he can throw the ball down the
field last night one for nine on throws
15 or more yards down the field with two
interceptions on those throws down the
field that's not working and you know
they're one and three in prime time but
i think the bigger issue is they're
faltering against the best teams other
than beating the packers who were up ten
nothing before the the the ceiling
crashed in on green bay
the the buccaneers can't beat the best
team swept by the saints lost to the
rams lost to a bears team that is
struggling to stay above 500 they're at
500 right now and i got the chiefs
coming up this weekend seven and five
feels like a a given at this point for
the bucks the question is after their
week 13 buy what can they do with the
last four games
you know here's the other question mike
i think it i think
we are so used to watching football now
and seeing quarterbacks
make plays going out of the pocket
and and that's what it it becomes so
noticeable
to see tom brady being
an old time classic pocket quarterback
when there are so many of them right now
so many quarterbacks how many 20 or 25
that get out of the pocket with ease and
seem to enjoy throwing it on the run
it's just not the case with the bucks
and to me
i think that makes it all the more
important that they add another blocker
up front and no matter what it does to
the number of wideouts you send
it's imperative that they get a sixth
guy on that offensive line at least to
me
yeah you're right the best quarterbacks
can make another play happen with their
feet when the play that's called goes to
pot
the
the buccaneers have a quarterback who
can't do that they've got to make the
play that's been called work and it's
not working nearly enough especially in
big games that's it for this edition of
pft on yahoo he's peter king i'm mike
florio we'll see you again next time
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports